[Music]
thank you
hello good afternoon and welcome to
sidetrack
your Sci-Fi TV movie channel and we are
I'm not sure guys
one second
Jesus wept okay I don't know what cause
that but we'll go back to it in one sec
let's see let's rejoin
is that a little better oh thanks guys
sounds all right so far no to me all I
could hear was
um but now I can hear you so that is
good
um right so
if you didn't hear me well because
today I'm not being joined just by one
American oh God no because one American
is never enough I'm being joined by two
Americans
kill me
I I this is my idea so everybody please
in the Sidetrack family say hello to
Harris from M cubed howdy
hello hey oh yeah and we are joined also
by Stormy in his new house which I think
is a bathroom and he's got his head in a
bucket but it's a little echoey but he's
still here he's still
flying that flag our resident American
stormy bear hello hello how the hell are
we both
fantastic
inside bonus of not only we have two
Americans you have two Californians I
know well
exactly I mean I don't really know even
how to answer that all I know is
that Harris's presence on this channel
today and low is the average age of the
presenters by perhaps three decades
um and I also hate how much Harry's got
so much meme you know
just get into the comments everyone to
tell a sandwich we hate Harris's
um luscious locks plastic So
today we're not talking about anything
in particular there's nothing even
though I do have something I want to
moan about but we'll get into that in a
sec but we are just here to have a chat
get to know Harris
let's store me moaning about whatever he
wants to moan about this week
and everybody get in this comments if
you want to ask us any questions tell us
anything that's interesting to happen to
you this week you are more than welcome
but we normally start these videos just
by having a little bit of a what have
you been watching this week what's hit
you what's been good what's been
shockingly bad
um so as Harris you are
um new to the Channel please let us know
what what have you been up to this week
sir um also please tell us a bit about
yourself while we're here while we're at
it okay well uh I will say that's that's
the first time I've ever been able to
like claim California and be kind of
proud of it it's taken me a while it's
I've been here for two or three years
now in LA and uh typically I'm a Texan
but I'm a Texan uh stranded in
California at the moment uh hence the
howdy of course
so uh this one's been pretty laid back
for me thankfully I'm gonna play right
now and that has kind of been gung-ho uh
and we had I think a nine day break in
the middle so that's been very nice
before our next performance tonight then
we got one more to Mara and uh
so you're an aspiring is that fair to
say
moment at the moment I like acting I'd
rather be behind the camera but I have a
love hate thing with acting and I'm I'm
going for it one way or another
good man right if you have a passion you
have a dream man go for it because I'm
British so I chose not to
um I decided to have a family and to
crush my dreams but um I feel like I'll
I've been watching a lot of marriage
with children recently
I don't know why I feel like I'm like
I'm watching now I'm watching Al Bundy
now this is way too old for you her
sorry but I want you to be in there
Katie Sagel is one of my favorites ah
she's amazing but I'm watching Al Bundy
now and I'm like I'm turning into Al
Bundy
I oh no again
unfortunately
um I didn't even know I was doing it
until I was watching a video and they
were saying that's all and I was like ah
crap that's what I do
I'm old and grumpy I can't help it
um as long as it comes with the good
quips you know the clever clips that
come with it
you know it's like with age comes
stupidity I find and um and then you
know and then you may you make more and
more comments that nobody else
understands because because uh you have
to have been in my brain 20 years ago to
understand the joke but what are you
gonna do
how about you as were Sci-Fi TV and
Movie Channel no house
um and you're an actor have you got any
um I I know you've appeared in the
background in a couple of projects and
things yeah exciting
uh
depends on what you call exciting we're
working on a couple things I guess uh at
the moment but the my biggest thing so
far I guess is I am the lead in a
documentary even though you never see my
face I I'm just reenacting uh
the possible killer from the starred
Rock murders it's an HBO Max
um I think they have maybe three or four
different documents like little episodes
on the docu series on there that was
cool it was fun yeah I gotta kill some
old ladies in the snow and then they
always would beat me over the head with
some binoculars and drag me down for a
little bit so that was some fun stuff uh
I got to do some stuff in the prison
sales it was
uh when they drop the soap leave it
leave the soap okay don't don't be
bending
anything's prison thankfully so it
wasn't too too bad yet
but we haven't been in search by that
now it's a little more uh fatty not so
uh Dove Dove Men's Health Care or
whatever it is now
it's very cool have you have you seen
anything on the TV in the last couple
weeks you've enjoyed while we before we
have to talk to the other Americans yeah
well uh that nine days have been kinda
nice and then steady and smooth I've
been watching probably too much for my
own good I uh finish stranger things I
had to I finished
Umbrella Academy started and finished
season three of that finished the boys
of course as we had to delve into some
boys uh that's always fun
uh and then it's been movie week for me
I saw Thor when it opened on Thursday so
Top Gun and 40 on Wednesday which that
was the most badass thing I've seen all
year I mean I don't know everything
everywhere all at once still gets me
just I love Multiverse stuff when it's
done well but yeah yeah
Top Gun with and 4D it felt like you're
flying with Tom Cruise it was great uh
and Tuesday I saw the black film which
was a great horror movie so yeah and
been busy
still not saying though this has got to
be the first Marvel movie I didn't see
in the first like two days of it coming
out just because the family's stuff and
being busy I've not seen it yet and I'm
like
oh I see oh it's it's good did you were
you a fan of Ragnarok yeah yeah I love
Ragnarok I thought Ragnarok saved Thor
Ragnarok but this might have been just
a little too taika I've I've heard they
go a little bit too far is has been the
it's actually got a really crap Rotten
Tomatoes score
it's it's like the third worst or
something in Marvel industry so I think
it's really bad
um but I mean but yeah apparently the
thing is they go too far with the jokes
and the silliness but
it's weird but
their debut was 300 million dollars so
oh yeah no money wise has done very well
yeah I think it's that it's the the
biggest debut of any Marvel in history
really I saw it on it was a variety I
think it was or this morning yeah it's
huge huge numbers I mean I I guess it is
the first
fourth
Single Character film yeah Solo
character film oh my plan these are the
most this is now the most isn't it
because Iron Man had three Thor's had
four cups in America at three
Spider-Man had three
but I don't think Spider-Man really
counts
but yeah I think there'll be a fifth
even though I don't I just hope they I I
assume no spoilers but Thor survives
right
Thor survives okay so uh the way you've
said that makes me suspicious we'll see
um
yeah so we'll see but um I hope they
don't have another one good well
how about you stormy before we get into
anything what have you been
well the uh you know I've been moving
this last week and
um I didn't want to get into anything
new to me and my girlfriend we even
watch re-watching uh the Marvel series
kind of in order
um we crapped out last night in the
middle of uh infinity War this is too
late tonight and so maybe today we will
start back and finish that up with uh
uh the last one of that series and um
try
we still I think we got one more episode
of the boys uh the two last episodes of
stranger things then we have to you know
I think we're going to do Hall Hogs and
um
I think is that correct yeah that's
correct
confirmation confirmation yeah excellent
news Excellence you know I I can't I
can't get my head around the umbrella
project
you've both mentioned that you're
watching it I've watched the first and
second series I've not watched the third
series yet
I'm I gotta be bored
you haven't seen the dance the the dance
off the dance off is great
I've not seen the bad stuff
it's gloriously
yeah you know it's gloriously weird and
I like that it's gloriously weird but to
me it's sort of like it's the wrong kind
of weird it's just weird
and I don't quite
this I don't know it feels a bit more
humor in it maybe or something or else
maybe just I'm not getting it but um was
it a big comic book very popular in
America or something I don't really know
the history I thought it was
Okay so we've never heard of it over
here so it's coming it just appeared on
Netflix and I was sort of like I wonder
what that is but mostly you know these
days most of the Sci-Fi you've seen at
least that's produced on streaming
services all started in with the of
course the exception of Star Wars and
Star Trek most of them are common quests
um I mean you know a lot there's a lot
of really good stories I mean yeah I
feel just horrible because I'm so old
going into comic book here are some
great Stories being told in graphic
novelty I mean
Walking Dead
you know uh can you watch the series or
the the second kind of the The
Watchman series that HBO did excellent
um
you know but um
they didn't come from Comics books they
come from novellas or short stories or
things like that only so so often you
know like book Rogers
I mean and I think parents would agree
with things like Hollywood is just out
of correct idea
oh it's it's insane I mean just I moved
out here right before the pandemic and
it's a whole different town now oh yeah
and that is really good it's just it's
still
out of touch and in touch all at once
you know it's it's kind of it's
Hollywood it's a conundrum in itself
it's interesting yeah I see a lot of
interviews with actors that the actors
that seem a little bit more down to
earth anyway and they all say that La is
insane
City it's an insane place to be that
it's it is like dream world sort of
thing lala land is the definition of it
is
when I first moved here I I interned uh
at a place for a year that was right on
Hollywood Boulevard so it's the best
idea right to go move right off of
Hollywood Boulevard I was half a corner
of a street away from the Chinese
Theater right under the Magic Castle and
uh
okay that was interesting for a year and
a half
I saw a lot of
I mean I'm a Texas boy at Hearts I don't
even get on the Subways out here I
needed a little more open land so now
I'm out in the San Fernando Valley uh
and uh this it's nice now I got fruit
trees in the backyard I have a yard to
take care of life life is good much
better than it was in Hollywood but then
I had to get out of Hollywood it's
it's too much way way too much
I got a question who's the most famous
person you've you've spoken to then
Harris you'd say
not just sin actually like happy words
with because this idiot over here stormy
spoke to Chris Pine and didn't know who
he was talking to really yeah
oh yeah every single week I wanna
slapping for it
um it was Star Trek too though yeah Star
Trek hadn't come out okay okay it was it
was about to
installing you have to remind me I know
you would when you're Cinema it did not
come out yet he made it but it won't
come out yet no he he okay so we're in
San Francisco at the time and uh
the San Francisco
I went there as a member and I went to
go see it and it was uh miracle
um
anyway you met Chris Pine and yeah
Napa Valley beat the French in one
competition right
and he played the character bobert and
as a habit I never read spoilers I don't
read movie news because I want to go to
the theater and experience it as the
interaction right smart you know and so
Chris Pine was there in the audience
you know uh production of Star Trek and
I just had no clue I thought we were
talking NASA we're talking wine you know
um
you know how you know just talking shop
you know I mean I had worked in the
movies and movies the previous thing
like 1980 something yeah
but you know I thought how was it we've
been working with Alan Rickman I have no
the worst Star Trek ever crossed my lips
and maybe that's why it's so comfortable
because no one mentioned it yeah
oh this you didn't know who you were
talking to yeah
that dude is awesome yeah yeah at least
that allowed you to have like a good
conversation with them and not yes yes
Carl I knew exactly who Dave Grohl was
and I stood there going uh uh it's Dave
and then that was it and he just walked
away he went okay and walked away from
me I'm out
but I still met Dave that's great he
thinks the English are dribbling idiots
that only just they just randomly shout
your name at them if you simply meet you
but um how about yourself Paris have you
ever met anybody that's just like
I've met a few people I think the people
that I've got to like have
the person I've had the longest
conversation with was uh everybody's
favorite commercial guy is Dennis
Haysbert uh the All-State guy he was in
the playing with fire movie which was
John Cena's movie right before
Peacemaker and Suicide Squad okay I do
remember that movie uh-huh that was the
company I interned for when I first got
out here so I got to go on the set and
see the the last little bit being made
and uh talk to the dentist out there
which was really cool and then Judy
Greer is also in that movie and I got to
talk to her she she did a little she's
talked all of us that was a lot of fun
oh that's nice and then you punched John
Cena in the face oh of course obviously
I mean because you would you I'd slap
him on his forehead he's gonna even beg
it for them I didn't see him and then he
turned around and surprised me so I had
to hit him real quick you know
spark him out anyway obviously that's
not true but anyway
it tell me a story it would be a story I
think we should just come on when you're
thinking because you know you should
just make sure
if you get off a chance we don't know it
could be true yeah maybe Ben I poked his
mum in the face and it could be true we
don't know she was there she left with
me after yes exactly I went with poker
in the face you went with taking her to
bed we're learning a bit more about
Harrison look at his Bakery we had a
nice evening out it wasn't anything
crazy I returned her home by 6 30. it
was it was a good day that's an old
person's bedtime yeah Okay cool so yeah
that was cognizant
so you know I would let my daughter know
any so that's all good I mean if
somebody wants to work in film you know
um
internships are a great way to do it uh
I originally interned with Warner
Warrior brother has a film Tech and I
worked on Tim Burton's Batman
[Music]
15 years before Harris was born
huh yeah Paul Harris was born or 88 that
was I guess about 11. barely I was so
close
I I beat the century by a year
then the next internship I did was in
Simi Valley for precision effects
um I worked on the really just a couple
projects I worked on deep dive suit for
uh the abyss oh really um
the Precision effects also did the uh
made up all the
Kardashian uniforms or DS9 the early
ones that were in uh
I think it is
for another
Star Trek project I can't remember what
it was like next generation or something
where the Corvette they had like two
Kardashians in itself and the other one
was working on the uh the Hall of
violence for the the mannequins in the
Hall of violence for demolition
and then there was a big earthquake
Where I lived and I said [ __ ] this [ __ ]
and so I moved to North Carolina and
started doing uh prop effects the
special effect makeup there okay that's
that's a hefty project together
and then I and then I got sick of that
and I moved in there
all right and make golf commercials for
years
I like it though that's awesome the
abyss is
people forget about the abyss but that
might be my favorite James Cameron
you know there's a couple of new movies
you know there's a few moves in there
that they just don't ever need to even
think about remaking so which means they
probably will at some point but the
abyss I I watched about 18 months ago
and those effects
still stand up yeah yeah the liquid
oxygen just mesmerized me as a kid and
it still looks just
perfect almost
yeah interesting
now the soon we won't talk about the
suit that's something I know about is
when you put Ed Harris in it they filled
it up with you know what you see in the
water filling up and that was on the
fact they actually
they had to they put it all in there but
the lens to the suit was Amber
oh okay you know and that was
interesting that was just that you know
like one of those double-layed things so
it looked like it was filling up but it
wasn't well we just swapped no out
that's just too much mechanical
engineering we just you know and so when
he's they're filling it up it's an Amber
lens and when it's all drained out then
it's a clear lens for the face mask
wasn't it risk of drowning surely a
little bit yeah oh yeah the whole thing
had like a quick release on it and uh I
wasn't on set but the other
documentaries show that there was like
scuba gear guys and all sorts of other
emergency medical tags there to take
care of well there was I mean the whole
set was fought with like the the chance
of grounding and it seems like every
movie that James Cameron makes he tries
to drown all his actors yeah
water's not any exception yeah
yeah and because
um
somebody on that set had like a
really crazy free dive holding your
breath section session he's like
uh
is like 22 minutes or something stupid
is that holding your breath for like it
might even be higher than that now
three three days ridiculously
some record for like an encapsulated
free dive or something and I think it
was seven six and a half or something
like that minutes maybe and someone beat
it on way of water I think it might have
been Kate Blanchett I'm not positive
though yeah I think it was like
yeah um Winslet 46 blew everybody away
when she did a seven and a half minute
breath hold for one of her scenes in uh
Avatar
Avatar
Olympic standard that is like properly
your brain starts to die after three
minutes yes a normal person
I mean and apparently you know she did
train for but again Cameron
ground
for all of his actors
more than about 30 seconds no I I was a
swimmer and a smoker and I don't ask me
to hold my breath for more than a minute
and a half
that's mental I know I've got you guys
together I knew you'd have some
interesting stories anyway because both
of us got a call from background and
anybody that lives in La is going to
have interesting stores because that is
a town but um
you'll have 10 stories right then
uh yeah against because yeah being in
Britain we don't really have that
we have to like people offering you tea
and things a lot and uh
London sounds like it could be fun a
little bit Yeah London has its moments
and Liverpool is the place to go if you
want to see some really crazy crazy
stuff and your life for people sound
snatching from the side of their mouth
the guy come up to me in near Liverpool
and then and I'd ask for a bottle of
water I've had a show like a bottle of
water please and then this guy behind me
hello mate where are you from all
talking lady there I'm sorry
I I'm from England where the hell are
you friends talking a lot he died
but the best of it is if you go to
Liverpool when you hit around the four
or five pints Mark everything
all of a sudden it's like you're tuning
into about old radio
and then like BBC One it's just like I'm
like [ __ ] I can hear I can understand
you
stop
oh all of a sudden everyone's everyone's
awesome oh hello how are you no Let It
Go you were all like
what happened there but um yeah it's
it's a drunk I think they must all be
drunk but it's one of the greatest and
it's you know it's like
um you don't have many cities in the
world that have created sort of like or
I have the history that Liverpool's got
it's um and not not all good either a
little bit of slavery trade went through
there a little bit
a lot of money and you know a lot of
wealth through this line trade which is
um not something we're particularly
proud of but we saw the Beatles so it
evens out I think probably yeah that's a
joke it doesn't even happen
Jesus Christ I'm gonna get in trouble
anyway we're already in trouble you
don't know anything yeah and uh I do
know I get letters
see this is a real thing you can come in
here and say whatever you like I get the
letters so um go crazy see what you want
also of course since you're new here one
of the goals is to say so much
outrageous [ __ ] that he gets all of the
hat and we can just sit back and you
know smile yeah you don't have to read
it I will forward
yeah whenever you're ready sir I mean
you can really say some batshit crazy
stuff and it's it's me that gets suffers
for it
can you say something about gravity like
a few weeks ago and you had like all
sorts of people piling on
gravity I'm with you
oh flat earther
um what I said was
scientifically accurate and I got so
much crap for it I want email chain went
off like 30 emails and I just went like
I'm just saying because if you fall down
because of gravity and that's it that
was basically
and it was just like oh that's just
stupid but you know you some people get
excited about these things and he um you
know
that's the internet we can do it's
YouTube what are you gonna do yeah
talking about that though I did get a
comment today and I did I mentioned this
briefly to you guys but I will tell you
rough I might have to edit slightly what
this comment said because it was so bad
but it's going to take us into a little
bit of a conversation about woke I'm
afraid sorry again
um I did a video a little while ago
about the Orville saying that it's not
woke because I generally don't think it
is my understanding of woke is that it's
when the politics overtakes the story is
the main thing people get angry about
which I think that's the core of it so I
always said the story comes first with
the Orville so it's not woke even though
even though it deals with some you know
some issues and things
a guy come on commented today
um and he his comment was the Orville is
woke because it makes out blacks to be
super intelligent when they're not and
that was his comment
so this was a comment that I
owned an art about so my first instinct
was to block him
and my second Instinct was was no I
don't really like censorship even when I
disagree wholeheartedly with the
sentiment I don't really like censorship
um and my third sent my third thought
was I'll argue with him and maybe I can
reason with him and then I went straight
back to the first one and just blocked
him because that's just I'm I'm not
having that sort of thing my name is on
this channel
so I mean it's like
um so first of all I would think what
I'd love to know what would you guys
have done in masses because you both
have YouTube channels I'm sure you both
get stupid comments sometimes what would
you if I had some comment like that
you know the only things I really delete
is
um comments like
um
stormy your [ __ ]
stormy your [ __ ] stormy get off the
internet stormy we hate you
I kind of leave those up there the ones
that's like somebody advertising or
putting a link to some sort of dating
site or some sort of yeah but if
somebody says something like that I
would leave it up and then I would
embarrass the ever love of [ __ ] at all
in the comments you know I would I would
leave it up and then I would just go to
town because that kind of a comment I
mean my definition of woke is anything
that embarrasses conservatives
you know they don't want to talk about
you know the American slave trade and
how you know this the state of South
Carolina and Florida in North Carolina
most of the South American South
benefited greatly about that and it took
the death of 600 thousands Americans to
make blacks and at least somewhat free
in America
600
000 deaths during the Civil War and it
was all about slavery and that's not a
woke statement but the conservatives in
America will say that's a very work
statement because it was about taxation
but if you read the letters in every
state that seceded send a letter to
Congress listing out the reasons why
they are seceding and every goddamn one
of them was about slavery and slave
owning and slave trade
you know so you know I we especially
this topic
you know I mean it is I mean I used to
go to Clan rallies and counter protest
and I had the [ __ ] that I made one of
them by klansmen so they can all kiss my
ass but yeah something like that I would
I would leave it up there and I would
use it as an opportunity to show other
people
what the reality is you know someone
just says I suck well you know I suck
the best
you know you do suck best
yes how about you Harris can you use
that the best oh God no I'm terrible
I'm not answering that question right
there
but no I I honestly that's probably what
stormy would do it's probably a
along the lines what I do I'm not big on
censorship in general but
you just don't you you don't want to and
encourage any variation of an
environment that'll allow that you know
uh
so it if you don't do it yourself I
guess it's good to have a channel
moderator that might go in there and do
something like that just so it looks a
little more uh official but um
yeah it's not right to deal with stuff
like that I do promise that anybody that
does a super chat I will read about and
I'll actually
a little bit agree with basil how does a
regulatory the horrid period of slavery
in America when the same five years ago
help people today so
I I would argue I totally I totally
agree with you that you know I just said
about Liverpool having a horrible
history I'm British
we invaded we invented the concentration
camp
we invented
um horrific Warfare you know you've
looked at what we did
um in South Africa when we took that we
turned up at India and basically went
we'll give you this money but we want
your entire country please and then we
did some really shitty things there as
well we caused Mass poverty in areas we
also brought Railways to most of the
world
um including your fine country and
Technology to a lot of the world and we
insisted everybody became Catholic for a
while or Christian and Church in England
for a while you know so we brought you
religion thank you're welcome you know
one point is we did some really crappy
things but we did some really amazing
things as well but should I feel guilty
about it
the crappy things that we did
well I don't know the crappy I don't
think if you acquired it's
an issue of the Next Generation
remembering or understanding what went
on
uh before I took the historic uh uh with
uh Virgin Galactic I was teaching
college
in California and
my students one of them asked and
they're all oh God all of most of them
were born after 9 11. and somebody asked
me why was Nick Richard Nixon so bad
and he had he just had no concept so I
went down the whole room because I lived
there I went down the whole register of
things
was not Watergate because of the last
three apologies
went through Vietnam then I went to
Watergate and then
um being China and it was like oh I had
no idea I mean I've always heard people
[ __ ] about Richard Mill House mixing
but I never heard anybody explain why
you know and there's and and this guy
was like 19.
and he just had no clue you know and
they want it's not his faulty but he's
younger it's just he didn't live through
it and so it's not you know I know basil
doesn't maybe want to talk about it but
uh but thank you for the five dollars uh
but you know it's not regurgitating the
horrible period of slavery in America
it's repeating it so no one else forgets
it yeah we um America was built by
slavery up until the Civil War you know
and
hundreds of thousands of people were
enslaved against their will and treated
absolutely horribly I remember if you go
to in Georgia there's Stone Mountain
State Park which has three Confederate
leaders chiseled on this humongous piece
of Grant I mean it's a mountain you have
to take a truck a cable car up to the
top
and it was so shameful to the to the
tour guide that took you around to uh
there was like this set on a plantation
and there were these slave quarters and
they were like you know got the size of
one of my bathrooms here and 12 people
be living there the the white tour guide
was so ashamed of what they did to
people in Georgia a hundred years ago
that she said
uh she did not want to interact with
black tourists that were coming down the
path
you know and in America when uh and a
lot of people discussed the taking down
of confederate soldier uh statues here
in America they failed to see the
inscriptions on the base of a lot of
these
a lot of these uh
statues that says it's that it's
dedicated to white supremacy right there
it says it chiseled in Granite
you know these statues were put up to
put down black people
you know into trample black people just
like the comment you got you know
because you know that you got you know
saying Orville as well because black
people aren't that clever
and and until we all get off of that
goddamn Insidious kind of thinking that
black people can't contribute to America
or to humanity
you know Black people quote unquote gave
us the pyramids black people were using
Pythagoras's Theorem before Pythagoras
was ever born a thousand years before
but yet their their theorem isn't named
after an Egyptian mathematician it's
named after Greek White
it's fine to remembering atrocities in
the past to not repeat them again but
all the work stuff is doing is vitriol
as those things were still happening
today as if those things were still open
today it would be like blaming modern
Germans for the Holocaust
from basil
um
it's not the stormy show yes it is a
little bit Harris
where do you come in on that
I mean I I definitely see what Basil's
saying with that most recent the 20
Super Chat right there uh
it it's you don't
I guess but I honestly one of the the
things that just to make it as simple
and mundane as possible a lot of it is a
saturation problem with which is what we
have with a lot of everything right now
and such a pertinent topic that we
should you know
learn about know about and use to
progress our future and then know what
not to do
if if it's in every single little piece
of media I guess it does dilute it over
time and
it makes it kind of in your face which I
guess is what people think of when
they're saying oh it's so woke it's so
woke
um it's it's truly not but in the in the
fashion I guess it's presented it can be
just because it's always there
it gets a bit but it needs to be talked
about it just needs to be talked in
about talked about in a
I'm I mean I I'm from Texas I'm from oil
country where I'm from so I grew up
money's a good thing but in in the film
industry just where I am you know it
needs to have art behind it and I I
think if it becomes just a a sticker to
toss on it like a whoa sticker uh
whatever I'm on this side politically
just kind of sticker on there uh it just
dilutes it it's it's an oversaturation
problem in that manner and it loses its
art which every piece of media should
have honestly basil brings up a really
good point about Germans in the
Holocaust and how they deal with
here in America because of things being
considered low
we uh many states banned their textbooks
that talk about the the American slavery
in a French manner we banned those we
don't want anybody talking but the way
the Germans deal with it they talk
openly about all the hordes of the
Holocaust but the people that they
celebrate are the people that are
working behind the scenes underground
you know uh helping you know with
against Hitler's war effort working to
hide you working to get these out of
from Poland from Berlin and to I think
uh London there was like a there was a
mass community of secret shipping from
France and then a lot of them then
carried on to America
look at thousands of the Jewish
population left Germany through either
through Norway
um or later through
um through yeah and then through London
into I think I look at the expansea it's
a perfect weight I will read Super Chat
I always will I look at the expansion
that is the perfect way to show
diversity all the most powerful
characters of black and minorities and
no vitriol which I would agree with it's
totally yeah it's not that's not a work
I do think people that argue about woke
the ones that are thoughtful right and
this is going to be my point here about
why I actually decided to delete the
comment
the ones that are actually thoughtful
and saying that right there is a problem
in some
um media and some movies and things like
this that because they're going to
because the ideology goes before the
story and the example I always think
about is Ghostbusters with boobs I can't
know what it's called 2016 whatever it
was that film forgot about being a
Ghostbusters movie and they got there
were some stories about the or that
women can't do this and I think the
filmmakers just went we bloody can and
they forgot about what they were doing
and it became a propaganda movie almost
not quite but you know to me
um
that does happen but I do think there's
an argument to say that Hollywood has
been so racist and so sexist for so long
some filmmakers just want to try to
counter the balance they're just doing
something like let's try she said we
we've been we're so ashamed of our
industry
can we
even out a little bit maybe they've gone
too far I think that happens sometimes
um
but sci-fi and that's what we talk about
here and there's you know that's what we
love in sci-fi and fantasy and all these
sorts of things for me sci-fi has always
been woke always has been oh yeah
original Star Trek yeah
it wasn't subtle it was in your face
racism bad and that was you know that
was the point
so but my point is though if you have a
group of people that are shouting and
basil I would say honestly this word
woke
is getting twisted into being something
really really negative and when because
you're being connected it's like being a
nationalist having national pride
unfortunately if you say I'm proud to be
British I'm proud to be a Texan I'm
proud to be whatever the Hellstorm is
from
um I've got halfway through the sentence
I'm so sorry
um but you know then all of a sudden
you'll for me to be I'm proud to be
British I'm lumping myself with a group
of people that you know unfortunately
have tattoos that are questionable
um in this country they all shave the
Reds they have very questionable tattoos
and they all love their mom for some
reason I love my mom on tattoos they
have Bulldogs
or or peoples and they vote for
something called the BNP which is the
British nationalist party now in theory
the BNP is just a political party that
that says we should put Britain first
which is a questionable ideology
immediately but unfortunately they're
just racist by putting Britain first
what they mean is everybody that's not
British off
that's not pretty no they're not a good
group of people
um but the problem is but if I put a
British flag out my window I'm I can
just be proud to be British that doesn't
mean I think we're better than anybody
else on the planet but I'm lumping
myself in with these idiots
by just just because it's not fair but
it's just the way I think people that is
that are thoughtful and actually
identifying that there is a problem in
Hollywood at the moment and some of
these projects are more about the
politics than the art
have a point but you're lumping
yourselves in with people that go
make comments like that today which
genuinely think black people are not as
clever as white people which is just a
nonsense because we're all human beings
under the under the skin it really
doesn't matter your skin I mean there's
never been true like the richest man
that's ever been alive was Mansa Musa
that'll just that immediately there was
thousands of years ago that immediately
dissipates that you know people even
knowing it so I always want to think
about something where I said I mean you
know it's you know racism is not
something that you're born with you have
to be taught my original my grandfather
he is
there's a Lebanese thing that lives
across the street and I never could talk
to their kids because they were off of
course the dirty
uh
but I think something Laura said
concerning you know maybe making up for
what I've done in the past I mean you
got you got guys like Harvey Weinstein
not the nicest guy in the world right
and the one in other parents I'd like to
get your comments on how many filmmakers
are trying to make up for what teams
very negatively did two people on set
and behind the scenes trying to get
away from that and I'm wondering if some
of that telling stories without you know
as we call it raping you this the
actress
in an honest fashion getting that kind
of
toxicity out of filmmaking and sometimes
the audience may think they're going to
say I don't know what you're talking
about
yeah it's it's
not easy to even
start with that you know is did you how
do you you know uh
I I think one because I mean Weinstein
was a producer and a lot of that a lot
of
locisms per se and every level of this
comes from producers because they're the
people that are getting the film made
and their ideas are in the film whether
the director likes it or not a lot of
the time or the writer
um
if you go on a movie set here you've
probably heard that is nobody wants to
[ __ ] the writers
I've never understood that
people Sylvester Stallone is an academy
awarded and writer and nobody gives a
flying crap they just take the mission
there's a couple of Academy Always
written several companies got no respect
because he only wrote it if you'd have
directed it he'd have loads of respect
yeah no sense to me at all
he only came up with the entire story
but uh the value was like penniless too
yeah he was that close to when Rocky
came out wasn't he to having nothing
it's 75 bucks and then there goes Rocky
everybody
I wanted to read it before
right okay wait a second from
Battlefield stop giggling now and then
put the camera it's glorious
okay
sounds like I do understand why writers
are antagonized by crap like that
nope don't get it eight years old you're
just a troll you know this is always
You're just calling okay well he's gave
me thirty dollars so Happy Days
um right now
um
I I genuinely think he's got a I'd like
to say I think he's got a point I think
some people that are thoughtful about
this woke I just wish they'd come up
with another word for it
um because they're they're just going to
be lumped in with all the racists
unfortunately in the sexist and the
people that genuinely think
um
if a black person is a hero on the movie
it's unbelievable somehow because I mean
there are people that think like this I
don't understand it it's it's so far in
the move from anything I sense I do
appreciate I do understand the argument
that like should we still still be
guilty about slavery
in some parts of the world yes because
unfortunately it's it still has an
effect well it's still happening it's
something racism is still happening yeah
and they're just you know racial based
slavery but gender-based slave you know
how many women like how many women was
in that's the worldwide sex ring sex
slaves
you know that uh oh what was it Maxine
is well whatever the last thing was
Epstein New Balance
but just you know and I think the term
worked you got to understand the source
is the the the people that popularized
the term woke here in America is Fox
News
it goes back further than for Fox News
it's become a negative thing thanks to
Fox News
all that it was an anti-race
it was like people are waking up to the
fact that racism is still happening
um oh yeah that was I thought it was
like a little hippie like it was
becoming awakened like enlightened
almost
enlightened in the fact that treat
people like people you know a little bit
I might go back to it you know and now
it's Fox News
yeah I promise that way some individual
requires to change the person's mind it
will happen but you need to force to
change their minds it's organic process
I disagree completely well now you don't
force to change people's minds you you
can't use Force but it's not organic and
it's not evolutionary it's education
and we need to talk about these things
and we need to educate people because
like you said stormy people aren't born
racist kids don't understand racism or
sexism or anything and that mostly
um I saw some evil little Subs are
probably born that way but mostly
they're not they're they're taught these
things and it is an evolution but it's
it's not an organic process it's
education and if we don't talk about it
and we don't understand what the
problems are I am a British middle
classy white guy in in Britain I I don't
get racist comments against me
but I know people that do my friend is a
um he's he's a solicitor and he is he's
a black lady he's Nigerian friend he was
born in Nigeria and he came over here
joined the British army fought for his
country and then um when he left he
became a solicitor and he would turn up
for us going on a drink having a few
beers and then be like why man why are
you late again please stop me and I was
like I've never been stopped by the
police in my life ever
um he's just like that's about every six
months or so because I'm a black guy
driving around in a BMW
they think and and then because I got
stopped once my license plate goes in a
database because but you'd be amazed how
quickly they become very very polite
once they realized I'm a solicitor then
they become absolutely lovely
um that's his life every six months or
so if he gets stopped yeah and we gotta
get it we gotta get away from it same
thing in America you know and that's not
at least that's recent that's today
that's right now in Britain which we
consider ourselves a reasonably moderate
country yeah I would hope I I like the
way generally Europe not necessarily
does policing but I like that there's no
undercover cop cars everything's
okay so the lights are behind the grill
all on the motorways they're almost all
undercover yeah so you don't know
they're there
never mind then yeah they actually um in
some place forces because we've got a
big problem with truck truck drivers and
um like driving with like uh iPads on
the laps and things or not not
constantly so actually we have a couple
of our police forces bought trucks
undercover so they can drive up next to
them so they're tall enough to see in to
see what they're doing and so we've even
got undercover trucks Oh yes I want to
be that copper driving
what have you got today oh I've got the
I don't know the Vauxhall Corsa I've got
the big boy it's like original Fast and
Furious just jumping on the side of an
18-wheeler real quick yeah exactly oh
it'd be Wicked
um I do agree I can see the the you know
with thing as well subtlety with with
science fiction should have layers and
and we can move on from this
conversation because it's a it's a heavy
one but science fiction for me has
always been woke but it should have
layers and it should and there are
layers to the expanse it's not just an
act they're up there it is supposed to
be trying to teach you different things
um but Side Tracks I'm sorry Star Trek
um Stargate even all these dinosaurs
they're not just action there's there's
layers to them and that that's when
they're at their best is when there's
layers we don't always like those layers
but it's way my best
um it makes it more realistic get every
different character is going to have a
different Viewpoint somewhere you know
yeah
Matt makes a good point there and
Stephanie's asked me to to point it out
yeah it is sad
we had a female Doctor Who and some
people
kicked off because well it's a female
doctor who've only had males before now
is that where does that fit in and then
they go well the doctor's actually an
alien don't forget and they go oh yeah
and they move on but other people still
get really angry about it we've now got
a black Doctor Who he's kicked off again
the people are going well this doesn't
make sense and I'm like well he was
Scottish a little while ago
it is just stupid
um
but anyway that's what I think anyone
who've got to see closing arguments
before we uh because we're nearly the
hour mark stormy
my evening
so if a lot of times people feel that
they're being beat over there and I get
that there's been a lot of like the
Ghostbusters
foreign
these kittens come up with something you
know and so I do get the beat over your
head but you know
oh quote unquote these issues of
racial disparity and Racial equality and
gender equality
who has been in sci-fi for a long time
and I wanted to call everyone's
attention to the Sci-Fi book we read a
couple years ago by Kim Samuel Robinson
called 2312. it's about a terrorist
attack on a city on Mercury
and you know throughout the the book it
is it's hunting down the the whoever's
I mean they leveled the city they
leveled the city on Berkeley
and it goes to but you you a lot of the
story is who everyone has the kind of
like their own
Personal Agenda that they manufacture
they could go to a doctor and get
whatever done and it was about all of
the differences there's a lot of
different flavors going on in that book
and it was just it really wasn't like
beating your head over to Heaven it was
just like subtlet it's in the story that
kind of explained everyone's personality
and uh 2312 I hardly recommend it but
it's been you know
these sorts of issues have been uh
in sci-fi since we've been so far I mean
you know we talk about you know when
we're talking about workers in the
original Star Trek the Original Series
and everyone uh talks about uh the kid
the first generation kiss with uh Kirk
and Uhura
well they're also tend to miss that the
entire
Federation Klingon uh tension was
it was all about the Cold War which we
were in the middle line and I don't know
if UJ had to do uh nuclear uh explosion
drills in there in school but I have to
now we understood that um hydrogen under
table wouldn't help
we didn't do that
and back then the schools had Fallout
shelters built in
yeah we couldn't afford that and all
those things are well we're prevalent in
the original series
of Star Trek and yet you know it's but
everyone focuses on what two seconds
between the forced in the script and
it's forced between Kirk and her and
everyone else bypasses all the other
stuff that was that Roddenberry put into
the original series and other ones
it just seems that there's just I mean
you guys can answer it for me because I
mean we live I don't think Britain is
particularly divided even though we do
us manga
um maybe around the whole brexit thing
people got a bit uppity but then
everyone seems to have calmed down when
everyone's actually didn't make any
difference
um but America if you watch the news you
guys are living there I'd love for both
of you together it seems like a divided
nation at the moment there's the
Republican and the Democrat and they're
a very very different idea we have the
conservatives in the labor party and
they're virtually identical
um they just one's red and one's blue
but really in almost every other respect
they're identical the liberal Democrats
will never win anything they're slightly
more relaxed they're like free education
for everybody and but everyone's like
and you're never getting in there so
don't worry about it
um
but the the policies for the labor party
and the conservatives identical I don't
that doesn't seem true is this just a
reflection of
a very divided nation Paris what what do
you think anyway uh I mean just humans
are naturally tribalistic and I think
going red or blue and then just having
like just two choices I mean our
founding fathers never wanted that from
day one you know uh
and it's it's immediately happened with
president number two of course
um
but it's tribalism just simply put and
we we want to have something to yell
about and it's easy to just kind of
prove yourself I might not believe one
whole full side but I'm gonna jump in
with them anyway and [ __ ] on everybody
else you're whatever it may be you know
uh it's it's
it is vitriol to quote basil over there
um
it's just not necessary I I guess it's
it's part of human nature to be that way
but America particularly has let that
like rot in us and and it's it's been
fed too much in the past 10 15 20 years
I guess and now
it's coming to its head with I guess all
the woke stuff which is again just
tribalism uh it's basic psychology we
call it in group out group and
psychology
um American News is walking until when
he first saw the TV grabbed a staff
weapon now I'm gonna require for this
yeah it is that's actually really
that's great I I watch Fox News I'm used
to BBC News which is supposedly supposed
to be very it's not always balanced it's
better than Sky News Sky News is
something is the other big news channel
here I watch Fox News Just for Laughs
sometimes there's also Fox News how can
you be and want to be fair CNN is just
as bad it's just the Democratic
um but I'm just like how are you saying
this with a straight face it's just like
I mean just like I mean seriously how
are you just this one-sided because
watch growing up with BBC News which
just tells you what's happened and
doesn't tell you what to think with it
watching Fox News is just like it's it's
not
it shouldn't be called the news channel
it's an entertainment channel it's very
funny I love watching it's hilarious but
it's not news because they're telling
you what to think constantly yeah I gave
up on American News years ago and
started watching BBC and Deutsche Villa
um
and I learned more about what's going on
in America from the BBC than I do CNN
MSNBC Awards office I mean that's how
horrible the news is
and you know we're talking about what
Harris was picking up on Juan Harris was
saying about tribals you know one thing
that a lot of people don't consider but
we only see the Democrats versus
Republicans and the number of pissed off
independent voters which I'm one of
those I don't belong to any party
we greatly outnumber those two groups
combined and nobody wants to declare
what we have to say because we're not
part of you we are our own little side
but we think there's and Three
Philosophers you know we can have you
know disagreements and not try to kill
each other or storm the capital or
whatever you know when we're also
concerned about our fellow man whether
we are here in our Tribune I mean that's
most of America and we're all
independent voted we don't belong to
anything
typically aren't combative
I don't care maybe they are but
there's it's just this the small size is
what's running the show is not the vast
of the majority of Americans does not
registered foreign
yeah
there's actually like um there's a bunch
of studies done on in Group now group
and it was really funny because I I have
come from a psychology background it's
so strange so that they did studies and
they found that even when if an in-group
um they would do like competitions and
things and you'd win prizes and win
points and they found that if sometimes
if you did something that um got your
team points that was you know they would
work hard and try to do it but actually
teams worked harder if it made the other
team lose points so if you did something
that affected the other team negatively
teams worked harder and were more
disappointed if they lost so I mean they
did something that was good for them
that was great but if they did something
that was bad for the other team that was
better
and all they did was your blue team and
your red team
and that's what they did and that's what
they found which is insane if you think
about it but it's what we see in the
world it's it's why we need to
understand psychology and understand
that way where that works
because um you can avoid it we are
animals yeah but we have executive
function yeah so we can override some of
those instincts I can think well
immediately in the face but then my my
executive function goes no come on
we don't like the Welsh in this channel
sorry I should have pointed out
um you don't even know the welshower
it's equivalent to not like in Ohio
Britain something like that
uh West but yeah
no it's fine the the thing is I honestly
think there's there's a funny thing in
there isn't that I'm I'm from I'm from
Telford so uh don't come and find me
iPhone 12 so I don't like the nearest
town shoes but don't like them
um but I'm English so I don't like the
Welsh but I'm British so I don't really
like the Europeans but I'm a European so
you Americans can [ __ ] man
you're telling me to go grab my Italian
neighbor right now right go for it
foreign
but it does it does make it ridiculous
though isn't it just ridiculous any sort
of hatred is when you put it like that
it's just like you know like England
in England football team will play Wales
and we're like I'm gonna kill him but
then Britain at the Olympics were like
come here my Welsh buddies they're gonna
go and beat the world and get in our
British team that's a good way of
thinking about it Andy Murray was
Scottish right up until he won Wimbledon
then he became British and we loved him
but it's just ridiculous and being angry
for it's mammalian part of our brains
but it's just stupid we're just gonna
try to but there's so much anger in the
world and it just seems to be getting
worse
but one thing uh you know super mystical
Mystic hymn Mystic and Lord uh
yeah it's just you know what we've
learned you know he says what we've seen
learned from our sci-fi shows and movies
you know it's
um
we are living in a Sci-Fi world I mean
these little things here they're
essentially Triforce right
um you know where I live there's three
companies launching satellites into
space there's three in this little
shitty town of Mojave where there's no
like gas stations and Paco stands and
that's it I mean we are living in the
future and I don't think people really
get
that you know right outside my door is
space travel
all the time and
there's there's like Tradesmen building
spaceships All Over America and it's
really hasn't sunk in you know he's
exactly we are living in a Sci-Fi world
you know I think we've talked about this
before in one of the lines from um
Firefly or loss says you know what's
just like says
yeah
the sound is going again gentlemen on my
end anyway right up my end
it's been right guys I I am going to
call it name because we are six minutes
overdue stormy
no no you stopped talking for a minute
so I I landed in the Stream
Harris you are welcome sir anytime
um but your hair isn't because I'm
jealous of it so um
please and and you need to like grow
like 30 years older wife
I used to look like the Stay Puft
Marshmallow Man it's doing a little
better nowadays I still look like the
staple of marshmallow man which is uh I
might I used to get
um if you got that thing in America was
a little fella that used to sell Pace
pastry how was that
boy yeah I got the Pillsbury Doughboy
quite a lot There's A You're Adorable I
like the [ __ ] dog boy
uh punch you in the face and that's when
you actually do it you let that part of
the brain do it yeah yeah no I left it
down I also got Ewok quite a lot I just
got called the Ewok quite a lot
so um because I'm I'm small and cuddly
but I will bite your face off if you
give me after I'm just at the Ewoks with
emotions Warriors in the universe so I
didn't actually mind that too much pound
for pound those those little things are
vicious they turned up with atats and uh
and they hit him with sticks and one
come on I'll take it might be comical
but at the end of the day realistically
those things are would be vicious yeah
exactly they were about to eat Luke and
Han and everybody too yeah exactly
people forget they were all on board
with eating
enchant chanting cheering around the
campfire they're excited about it
yeah
a vicious little buggers
before I say goodbye to you properly I
am actually going live in about 20
minutes with Matt to tell all of you
lovely people about an interesting
little change in the way I'm doing the
channel going forwards because I can't
be bothered now okay I can't be bothered
I don't have time and Matt is going to
be coming into helping me so we're going
to tell you all about that
um and please there is a link in the
description go and join Harris on mccube
where he talks about movies and
everything and marijuana occasionally
and and so he is a little you know all
those um those people that move in next
door and you've got stoners Harris is
one yeah but I'll feed you because I'm
from Texas too well there you go happy
days I mean that's the only real problem
with concerns is Munchies as long as
you're back to it of course sweet
um and obviously there's a link for
stormy's channel over there if you
actually want to go and learn something
um you've got stormy's Channel as well
please go check out the Luke's drinks
the description for both it's in the
description go and subscribe immediately
do it do it right now God damn it
um I'm not allowed to say God damn it
I've been told recently that I shouldn't
say that as well
because apparently that's um
uh God doesn't like it
sweet goddess in a tree
yeah as we got us in the tree okay I was
a little bit druidic but okay that might
fit since you're you know closer to the
Salisbury flame than I am
let's close it the Salisbury Plain then
you are I mean
I was born there
so
that's confusing I've confused me I was
I was I was weird I was actually born in
Salisbury
me
um
system Lord
yes what about system mode that's where
the fantasies
thank you again Harris you've been
mental and we will most definitely 100
see his handsome face again if he is
willing and stormy unfortunately he will
probably be back next week as well but
thank you guys see you all next time
uh damn it I forgot I've got an outro
and I forgot to do it again I'm ready
bye
[Music]